Benjamin Stora on va plonger dans vos
mémoires c'est un peu mon mémoire c'est
son beau souvenir l'arrivée de
Constantine à Paris c'est chez
Taillandier ça raconte l'exode précipité
l'arrachement de vos parents auquel vous
rendez hommage l'assimilation
l'émancipation aussi dans une société
française des 30 glorieuses parfois
hostile mais aussi généreuse on voit ça
dans l'invitation de Marion Becker on en
parle ensemble juste après
si on vous invite Benjamin Stora c'est
parce que vous vous livrez pour la
première fois en racontant votre enfance
les mémoires d'un gamin qui quitte
l'Algérie pour découvrir un nouveau
monde la France un périple de
Constantine à Paris en retraçant ses dix
années de votre jeunesse vous racontez
aussi à quel point vos origines
familiales ont déterminé votre parcours
intellectuel car Benjamin Stora vous
êtes historien spécialiste de la guerre
d'Algérie vous y avez consacré de
nombreux ouvrages en 2020 Emmanuel
Macron vous confie à une mission sur la
mémoire de la colonisation et de la
guerre d'Algérie
cette fois vous racontez votre propre
histoire celle de votre famille juive à
Constantine en Algérie l'arrachement à
votre terre natale le 16 juin 1962 vous
embarquez en silence pour la France avec
votre famille et huit balises
à Paris vous découvrez la pauvreté
l'antisémitisme dans le très chic lycée
Jean sonde Sailly vous expliquez alors
comment il vous a fallu oublier et
dissimuler votre propre histoire pour
vivre dans la société française pour
surmonter les épreuves de l'exil ce
récit est aussi celui de l'assimilation
et de la superposition des identités
dans l'insouciance des années 60 en
banlieue puis celle de l'émancipation
par l'engagement politique à partir de
mai 68 vous êtes alors trots vous croyez
en la Révolution la déchéance sociale
vécue par votre famille ni sans doute
pas étrangère
votre histoire vous rattrape à partir de
1974 vous commencez à travailler sur
l'histoire de l'Algérie après l'oubli
nécessaire vous devenez historien des
événements alors on a une question pour
vous Benjamin Stora l'historien que vous
êtes a-t-il été construit par votre
histoire intime
réponse réponse oui et non
l'historien que je suis c'est d'abord du
travail universitaire tout à fait
classique sur la base d'archives de
témoignages de presse etc mais on est
effectivement rattrapé par son histoire
intime c'est vrai peut-être c'est un
effet de vieillissement je sais pas
c'est après du temps pour vous de
décrire ce livre c'est un livre
personnel sans doute le plus beau
vous y êtes depuis longtemps qu'est-ce
qui vous a décidé depuis plusieurs
années en fait parce que il y a eu
plusieurs plusieurs événements bien sûr
le problème de la transmission de cette
histoire à mon fils en particulier je
pense que c'est des choses qui sont
importantes les mutations de la société
française le rapport à la nation à la
France à l'immigration à l'exil qui
s'est profondément modifiée ça c'est
très important
il y a aussi bien sûr
toute la question des réflexions autour
de des questions coloniales post
coloniales bon le président Macron
m'avait confié cette mission si en 2021
qui est très importantes parce qu'elle
touche des millions de personnes qui
sont touchées par l'Algérie donc revenir
aux origines on va partir de cette photo
la couverture c'est qui ce petit garçon
de 11 ans au regard pétillant voilà
c'est léger se léger sourire qui grandit
dans les ores à Constantine dans un
quartier judéo musulman où l'on entend
l'arabe où l'on entend la français bien
sûr et on lit l'hébreu à quoi ressemble
la vie à l'époque c'est une vie
communautaire déjà c'est à dire une vie
de l'entre-soi où les gens de la
communauté juive vivaient entre eux bien
sûr la communauté musulmane les
chrétiens vous voyez j'utilise des
termes de l'époque pour qui sont
toujours utilisés par les personnes qui
sont qui ont vécu cette époque
évidemment
mais aussi une ville cosmopolite
forcément c'est à dire qu'on parlait
plusieurs langues sans même s'en
apercevoir c'était une richesse dont on
percevait pas évidemment toute
l'importance que ça aura plus tard pour
moi en particulier dans mes travaux
d'historien donc une vie d'entre soi une
vie de gaieté parce qu'il y a beaucoup
de fêtes dans les religions parce que
c'est c'était une ville religieuse
Constantine c'était pas Alger c'était
pas Oran il y avait il y a eu beaucoup
beaucoup de festivités religieuses
beaucoup de cousins
Marthe il y a des photos où on voit les
tentes et les cousins tout le monde se
réunites beaucoup de rythmes religieux
et ridiculaire lié au rythes religieux
bien évidemment puisque c'est c'est les
fêtes qui rythme disons les plats qu'on
va manger donc c'est cette vie là bien
sûr il y a l'éruption de la guerre
d'Algérie quand même la peur vos parents
est particulièrement votre père il a cru
à cette vie jusqu'au bout quelques mois
encore alors que ça devient très
compliqué notamment pour pour les Juifs
que son magasin c'est un atteindre
semoule pour les Juifs et boycotter les
tensions sont là et continuent
d'ailleurs à employer ces deux personnes
musulmanes il y tient il y croit il y
croit parce que la famille Story est
issue de d'une vieille région d'Algérie
qui est les horaires il y a une autre
partie de la famille d'Alger bien sûr
c'est à dire qu'en fait les Juifs
d'Algérie étaient là depuis des siècles
et des siècles comment s'arracher à une
vie aussi ancienne c'était un dilemme
extrêmement cruel extrêmement difficile
et puis mon père aussi avait fait
beaucoup d'études en arabe littéraire et
un diplôme de droits musulmans de la
faculté d'Alger donc ils connaissait
très bien cette société
et donc pour lui ça paraissait quelque
chose d'impensable
pour la plupart d'ailleurs pour beaucoup
de gens ça paraissait impensable de
quitter l'Algérie parce que
effectivement
l'Algérie française il y avait eu le
décret Crémieux et la citoyenneté
française même si elle avait été arraché
enlever par Vichy néanmoins les Juifs
d'Algérie pensaient que cette égalité
citoyenne il ne pouvait pas la perdre
ils avaient peur d'ailleurs de la perdre
à nouveau alors ça sera pas le bateau
pour vous cette décision de départ ce
sera ce sera l'avion deux valises par
personne pas plus il faut tout laisser
derrière soi et vos parents vous votre
sœur vous prenez un d'abord un camion
militaire et puis jusqu'à l'aéroport
c'est le décollage personne ne parle
silence total et la nuit tombe c'est ça
votre dernière image en fait elle
n'existe pas en fait elle n'existe pas
la dernière image dans la mesure où on a
attendu longtemps sur le tarmac une
chaleur écrasante en portant des
manteaux parce que comme ça on gagne de
la place dans les valises
et lorsque l'avion a décollé
effectivement la nuit est tombée
brusquement et il y a pas de j'ai pas de
souvenirs d'une dernière image de
l'Algérie de ce pays qui va disparaître
dans tous les sens du terme il va
disparaître rapidement c'est le sens de
ce livre d'ailleurs c'est à dire le fait
que pendant tout un temps bah il y avait
cet oubli c'est oubli de l'Algérie leur
moi comment font de 12 ans bien sûr ce
qui était pas le cas de mes parents qui
étaient eux emportés par le chagrin
c'est ça qui est très important pour
vous ce départ il n'est pas si
douloureux mais vos parents sont déjà
âgés mon père à 53 ans ma mère 46 ans
donc ils ont fait toute leur vie en
Algérie c'est beaucoup plus difficile
pour eux pour moi non c'est une
excitation il y a la découverte d'un
nouveau pays la France dont on parlait
beaucoup à l'école partout qu'on
connaissait pas dans le fond on n'avait
jamais été en France donc il y avait
effectivement cette cette nouveauté
sensationnelle qui se présentait devant
mes yeux et donc aller vers la ville
lumière alors justement c'est important
la Ville Lumière allait sombre quand
c'est arrivé c'est un taudis alors dans
le 16e certes mais garage mis
appartement mais entrepôt dans lequel
vous vous arrivez rien n'est prévu
d'ailleurs pour accueillir ce qu'on
appelle les rapatriés oui c'est-à-dire
qu'en fait on était mais on le disait
pas comme ça à l'époque on était en fait
des réfugiés c'est lorsque j'ai par
exemple quand j'ai vu les images à la
télévision bien sûr de jésus-crainiens
qui quittait vous savez les villes qui
en guerre et je me suis souvenu aussi de
ce départ avec deux valises sans rien et
ne sachant pas s'il y avait la
possibilité du retour donc c'était
l'incertitude la précarité absolue et
effectivement on a atterri dans un
endroit improbable dans le 16e
arrondissement au cœur du 16e
arrondissement entre la rue du Docteur
Blanche et l'avenue Mozart donc c'était
quand même quartier très chic vous allez
rester deux ans scolarisé au lycée très
huppé de Janson saillie et là vous
raconter la honte de la pauvreté vous
racontez même
que vous faites semblant de rentrer chez
vous alors que c'est pas chez vous dans
de beaux immeubles parisiens pour que
vos camarades ne se doutent de rien oui
c'est-à-dire que dans cette exil
effectivement la question de la honte
sociale c'est imposée beaucoup plus dans
un premier temps que la question de la
perte d'identité
ou de la nostalgie du Père du Paradis
Perdu etc en fait la question sociale
avait tout envahi mes parents et mon
père en particulier ma mère aussi était
obsédée par la question sociale
c'est-à-dire trouver un travail trouver
un logement incroyable à l'usine Peugeot
ma mère a fini par devenir ouvrir
d'usine à l'usine Peugeot ou qui rit à
La Garenne Bezons et mon père bon grâce
à son diplôme en droit a pu travailler
dans une compagnie d'assurance mais
c'était une opérations entre guillemets
de survie sociale fondamentalement plus
que de souvenirs de traumatisme même si
dans l'espace privé familial en
particulier
une grande famille le souvenir
naturellement lancinant terrible de
l’algérie revenait mais la question
sociale était très importante faut pas
le l'oublier la question sociale la
question de l'antisémitisme aussi et
même si on oublie même si on est face
elle vous rattrape cette question là et
vous en faites l'expérience de façon
très différente de tout ce que vous avez
pu connaître en métropole dans le très
chic etième arrondissement oui
effectivement il y a une espèce entre
guillemets d'antisémitisme culturel
évident banal etc qui pousse d'ailleurs
à cette sorte entre guillemets de
dissimulation des origines c'est-à-dire
que c'est ce qu'on va appeler
l'assimilation c'est vrai c'est
l'assimilation c'est à dire ne pas
montrer du tout sa différence ne va
montrer qu'on vient d'Algérie donc il
faut effacer son accent bien sûr qui est
un accent très reconnaissable mais il y
a aussi bien sûr
l'identité juive bon qui qui va
s'effacer dans l'espace public alors
qu'elle était très présente
lorsque j'étais enfant donc c'est un
processus aussi qui qui s'accomplit dans
une modernisation très rapide de la
société française
la voiture la machine à laver la machine
elle avait les avions les aéroports les
autoroutes enfin bref on a une France
qui se modifie à une vitesse prodigieuse
comment vous vivez le regard qu'on porte
sur vous vous êtes perçu comme des
réfugiés dans votre propre pays comme
des réfugiés justement des étrangers non
plus on était ni des réfugiés ni des
étrangers ni des immigrés mais qu'est-ce
qu'on était alors on était des espèces
de français à part d'ailleurs ma mère
quand elle parlait souvent et mon père
aussi d'autres membres de ma famille
parler des français quand il parlait des
gens de qui vivaient à côté de chez nous
etc c'est à dire on était à la fois
français sans être vraiment français
c'est-à-dire qu'on parlait français on
aimait la culture française bien sûr
mais en même temps on n'était pas vu
véritablement comme des Français c'est
toute la difficulté de cet entre deux
qui était très compliqué et les années
Sartrouville après les années
copains le cyclisme le vélo le football
la culture ouvrière que je découvre bien
sûr ça va de Jean Ferrat jusqu'au Tour
de France c'est c'est là que je
rencontre le Parti communiste français
aussi qui est très fort très puissant à
Sartrouville et donc il y a une
fraternité nouvelle qui qui existe à
l'intérieur des cités ouvrières de cette
époque sans distinction d'origine
identitaire ethnique ou autre tous les
enfants tous les adolescents de cette
époque qui jouent au football ou qui
font du vélo qui font des sorties etc ne
se préoccupe pas de l'identité première
ça c'est très important ce qui va
expliquer aussi entre guillemets l'oubli
c'est-à-dire que on a aussi une volonté
d'avancer dans une société qui se
modernise très vite sans sans référence
à l'identité de départ sans assignation
sans assignation absolument mettez
l'éveil politique vous l'avez dit déjà
les premiers contacts avec le communisme
et ce Benjamin saura dont les cheveux
commencent à pousser de plus en plus
dans les années 70
Nanterre où vous allez découvrir
l'histoire commencer à vous tourner vers
l'Algérie d'histoire de l'Algérie ça
commence déjà là mais 68 l'extrême
gauche le lambertisme le trotisme vous
avez un blaze d'abord un blaze
soviétique puis ensuite vous devenez
russe vous devenez Truffaut c'est
l'émancipation la véritable qu'est-ce
que vous en gardez de ces années là en
quoi elles vous ont encore marqué
aujourd'hui elle participe d'un
processus d'assimilation culturelle en
fait entrer aussi dans cette histoire
française que je connaissais pas cette
histoire qui va de la Commune de Paris
jusqu'à la résistance etc donc c'est une
suite en fait fondamentalement d'autre
part c'est une sécurité une parce que il
y avait une incertitude quand même
sociale
qui a une fraternité qui se crée dans le
réseau militant qui est très fort parce
que on était un petit groupe à Nanterre
on était très solidaire entre nous et il
y avait beaucoup beaucoup de groupes à
l'époque à Nanterre c'est pas les seuls
évidemment mais ça crée cette sorte de
convivialité de vivre ensemble de
chaleur humaine que je retrouvais dans
le fond que j'avais pas vraiment
découvert dans les lycées où j'avais été
et que je retrouvais là cette fois-ci
spontanée
c'était une forme aussi de revanche sur
des classements des parents et il y a
effectivement une radicalité sur la qui
pourrait prendre sa rétrospectivement
que je l'ai analysé dans ce livre
effectivement par rapport aux
déclassement la chute vertigineuse
sociale de mes parents il y a une rage
effectivement sociale qui est très forte
moi j'étais fils d'ouvriers en fait
fondamentalement ce qui était pas le cas
de tous mes camarades
je vous invite à lire l'arrivée on
parlera de la question de la mémoire
plus tard vous reviendrez parce que
voilà les tensions sont encore très
dures très difficiles entre la France et
l'Algérie de Constantine à Paris
1962-1972 chez Taillandier le plus beau
livre je trouve de Benjamin